I I would say 90 of the sex that's being
had in America isn't necessarily
um happy willing sex it's it okay like
where I live the sex even even with the
guys which is weird it's like look you
you just [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what you do
just like you know when you're with a
guy if he wants to [ __ ] you [ __ ] him
because that's what you do you know and
like I don't think that a lot of people
even are having sex because they want to
it's just because that's what you do you
know that's
yeah or like okay with the women it's
more like well that's what you do for a
man if a man wants sex you know that's
what you do but with the men it's more
just like um the men that are doing it
like let's say because they don't
necessarily want to but it's a that's
what men do you know and they have to do
that to prove that they're not gay or
you know what I'm saying to just
basically
um I I also think the sex is a is it a
drug or means to get a drug well okay
well yeah for the women I would say for
the men it is definitely a drug it's a
huge huge addiction I think there's a
lot of